so yesterday CNN did this climate change
forum they had back to back town halls I
think it went seven hours in total each
candidate or many of the candidates I
don't have the full list of who even
participated in front of me as I
mentioned I just dipped in and out of a
few minutes here or there and then read
a summary the idea was let's go deep
let's go deep with each candidate on
climate change and one issue that keeps
coming up time and again and Elizabeth
Warren handled it really well is this
topic of plastic straws and light bulbs
and plastic straws and light bulbs are a
bogus distraction to the broader
systemic changes that need to happen in
order to really deal with the climate
crisis so there's a really good analogy
here and it's undocumented immigration
and wages this has been waged
effectively by huge corporations huge
corporations really are what keep wages
down huge corporations take advantage of
undocumented immigrant labor who is less
likely to push back against bad working
conditions because they know they're
undocumented and they know that they
risk if they start reporting things and
getting on law enforcement radar they
disk risk deportation so it is really
corporations that have to be blamed for
perpetuating and even encouraging the
status quo around immigration but
corporations have done something genius
they have fomented the idea that the
middle class in America and the lower
middle-class blue-collar workers they
need to be at odds with Latin American
immigrants they by fighting with each
other are lowering wages and bla bla bla
bla bla and it is worked brilliantly
because very infrequently do you
seriously hear the corporate
responsibility addressed when it comes
to keeping wages
you've got workers fighting workers and
that's exactly what corporations want
apply that to climate change the
building industry the electric power
industry and the oil industry are some
of the biggest polluters and biggest
sources of fossil fuel emissions and yet
they through corporate PR campaigns have
brilliantly put the focus on have you
switched off of plastic straws to the
paper straws or compostable potato
starch straws or whatever
have you replaced all of your light
bulbs with the CFLs which last however
long it is or whatever and Elizabeth
Warren was asked about this during her
Climate Change Town Hall on CNN and she
brilliantly called it out but do you
think that the government should be in
the business of telling you what kind of
light bulb you can have oh come on give
me a break
you know yes no here's look there are a
lot of ways that we try to change our
energy consumption and our pollution and
god bless all of those ways some of it
is with light bulbs some of it is on
straws some of it dang is on
cheeseburgers right there are a lot of
different pieces to this and I get that
people are trying to find the part that
they can work on and what can they do
and I'm in favor of that and I'm not a
help but I'm gonna support but
understand this is exactly what the
fossil fuel industry hopes we're all
talking about they want to be able to
stir up a lot of controversy around your
light bulbs around your straws and
around your cheeseburgers
when 70% of the pollution of the carbon
that we're throwing into the air comes
from three industries and we can set our
targets and save by 2028 2030 and 2035
no more think about that right there now
the other 30% we still gotta work on
this is the answer we can't let these
bad actors do the sense-making to borrow
a term from earlier in the show
something like 100 companies are
responsible for 71 percent of global
emissions framing is extremely important
when you look at the discussion of
Medicare for all we talk about the
economic benefits we talk about the
emotional psychological benefits of not
having to worry about if I get treatment
or if I get sick am I going to go
bankrupt there's all these intangible
benefits to something that is affordable
we've seen it time and again it is
affordable but you will hear this
concern
trolling of but but if we do Medicare
for all
some people will lose jobs medical
coders and insurance fraud investigators
and medical billing people those are
jobs that should not have existed in the
first place I've addressed this issue
already any time government does
anything there is a job impact even
policies that create 10,000 jobs might
simultaneously destroy 500 meaning that
the net benefit is only 9500 jobs it's a
red herring okay it is the idea of
putting pressure on people to fight
against each other for the benefit of
corporations and we can't be distracted
by this stuff fuel efficiency of cars is
another one listen if you can go from
cars on average getting ten miles per
gallon to 60 miles per gallon I'm not
pretending that that's not going to have
an impact but when you look at vehicles
versus cargo ships and aviation and all
of this other stuff it is again
pressuring the consumer to believe that
they are the ones who need to solve the
problem by not using a plastic straw or
by getting a hybrid vehicle or for
whatever the case may be and the whole
point of it is prevent demand for
corporate action and the way to do that
is prevent demand for government
regulation of corporations which is the
answer I mean what that that's just that
is the answer and that's where we need
to be looking that's why the narrative
and agenda setting power of corporate
media is so important and we can't let
them do it good for Elizabeth Warren for
shutting it down